welcome back to new rockstars i'm
phillip molina this is fitness origins a
fitness competition show where i use the
films of the mcu to torture
i mean inspire my fellow nerds on their
way to becoming superheroes
each episode we make our way through two
mcu movies in a row and now we're at
avengers age of ultron now it may seem
that the lesson in the movie is to not
trust technology but actually i think
it's all about how you
wield technology because after all what
is vision
if not jarvis persevering so let me add
our boys to the call and explain how
this all applies to fitness
hello my little enhanced twins hello
philip good to see you my friend why do
you have a russian accent
i don't know but if you just wait one
movie it will completely disappear
and you wait uh not to the end of this
episode and i will be shot in the street
like a chump
like a dog my brother
peter my brother right guys so uh you
guys know me you know i'm a bit of a
tech head and this week i really want to
lean into that aspect of nerdum and get
some
gadgets involved oh like these are
really slow to read
heart rate monitors that look like
better things but aren't
yeah no those are garbage we honestly
did we just put a sticker on an old
casio and
just told you it was your heart rate i
think ronald mcdonald is behind this
the reason we had to get you those is we
are on a very
limited budget here you guys remember
bridget last week oh yes yes she wiped
us out
oh worth every penny yes absolutely i
will be making payments for every year
but
i'm actually going to give each of you
guys 50
this time because i want you to still
find a piece of technology
that you can use to really step up your
workouts a bit but also
just have more information at your
disposal like i know for me my apple
watch and my smart scale does make a
huge difference whenever i'm trying to
lose weight just make sure
to not really trust the body fat
percentage if you do end up getting the
smart scale that's always going to be us
wait you want us to buy like a useful
piece of fitness technology with 50
dollars
what country are we buying it in yeah
hands-free shake weight is like five
times as much as that i think it's 250
bucks
and you have to fly to japan to go to
one of the cafes where they do it but no
hands-free
things that just do their thing on you
these are fitness products please and a
fifty dollar limit
oh please papa please 150 dollars
we have four who want to be a good
little boy
you're a perfect little boy okay
sleep on time it's 45 now
oh okay what's the opposite of what i
just did
yeah all right dad i'm gonna cause
trouble
look okay i'll give you guys 50 bucks
but this is an investment into yourself
right no that means that like spend some
of your own money
and just and get what you want this is
this is your health it should be worth
it i hear what you're saying spend a
little bit of our own money
close to 50 i've got an idea all right i
have a thought
all week let's see what more you guys
can learn about your human selves
by relying on your technological
counterparts
week six day one got the jogging in last
week i like that add an element of
cardio my body is a temple the temple is
in shambles yeah so i
just got my apple watch my smart watch
and uh i don't really know how to use it
yet fifty dollars that's obviously the
most money i've ever had in my bank
account
why not take some financial risks open
up some credit cards and uh make a
bigger investment myself so bam
purchase a peloton baby
look at that screen it's bigger than my
tv it's the biggest screen
i've ever owned financially responsible
absolutely not
kind of a cult maybe what i like about
having like a smart watch is it doesn't
really totally get in your way i'm not
letting it control my entire life
i'm on the internet joining facebook
groups somehow ended up in peloton moms
this freaking apple watch tells you way
more than i thought
hey siri how many calories did i burn
394 calories
i was finally able to get through the
full 15 minutes of hell
but because it's week six we're pushing
ourselves harder and i
[ __ ] doubled it i never thought i'd
be able to get up to this point we're
gonna do
32 minutes of pretty much non-stop hit
training
a little groggy today because i stayed
until 2am chatting with my uh new
peloton facebook group the pella fellas
hella fellas hashtag love you guys
hashtag
not crazy about the nickname you gave me
but i was able to scale up largely
thanks to just having like a simple
fitness watch keep track of all of it
for me but like
emotionally i feel like i left a hurdle
that i wasn't able to lead before
i almost missed my workout today because
i was doing a peloton
orientation group you kind of just get
to know other peloton people but i think
it's
starting to impact my ability to do
other things outside of that like i
don't know i was online about 12 hours
today just doing peloton stuff
i got a handle on the rings these rings
kind of
are keeping me honest throughout the day
i realize i'm able to hit
my uh exercise goals and then some and
burn the calorie goals and then some
it's like it's all automated now
all right we're at the end of the week
tommy what
were you thinking i'm a bike daddy now
okay
it's all about hills i take those hills
i take those valleys a flat surface i'm
not afraid of it
i'm about gains i'm about personal best
and i'm about my pella family okay
all my pelatomies out there pelotomi lee
pella tommy lee jones hello tommy
hilfiger our whole gang pelotoms
how much did that thing cost oh a lot
phillip we won't know the final cost
until it's completely paid off but i
locked in
a very reputable man named bizazz called
me and he said he could finance it
after i had signed up so what he did is
he made the payments for me and i'm now
paying him off over
at a pretty fixed rate over the next 25
years but what it was worth it i needed
the peloton brand in order to track
my progress on the bike we've got so
much data coming in and out that i can't
even really keep track of it anymore at
this point
tommy there that's not the only piece of
technology that you could have used look
i got this apple watch it's super simple
way more affordable they have an indoor
cycle function
on this they could have used i'm not
gonna lie that's pretty devastating for
me to hear because i am losing things
out of my apartment on a daily basis
they are
repossessing everything so at this point
if i could have just gone to costco and
bought an apple watch i feel like i
would be in a lot less trouble
are you at least getting use of the bike
tommy
i am the peloton is great honestly i
never thought i would be a peloton guy
but
that's the lifestyle it's i wake up and
oh it's time for breakfast no it's not
it's time for a peloton ride is it lunch
time yet no
you're not done with your peloton ride i
was with my girlfriend peloton last
night and we were pelotoning
and she looked at me and said i think i
want to spend the rest of my peloton
with you
i'm in no less than 15 facebook groups
we're discussing i'm in the pella fellas
i'm in the peloton moms i'm in the pella
felons which is all for convicted felons
it's more than a lifestyle it's it's
it's my everything now i i
i think about nothing else other than
the peloton it's ruined a lot of my
relationships eric
how are you liking your apple watch now
that everything i own is like
apple i'm in my own kind of cult it's
not ruining my life though um
i figured out the rings and i am the
lord of them
i don't always complete them they're the
lord of me those days
i have this weird relationship with the
rings so there is another kind of weird
cult
i feel like i should have been way more
specific because this took a real huge
turn
from what i said at the beginning of the
week all i was saying is like these
pieces of tech guys just about setting
very specific goals that gives you a
dopamine hit right
of seeing these points that you're
earning it could be percentages
timers that yes you are indeed making
progress
even if it's not so obvious at the
moment guys speaking of tech
that can help you on your fitness
journey
baby the doordash app of course that's
what we're talking about normally you
don't think of delivery as having
healthy options but
how often are you supposed to eat
something healthy and then it feels like
just way too much work to make
all the time if it's me uh and with
doordashes isn't any harder to get a
healthy still delicious restaurant
quality meal to your door it's as easy
to get a not so healthy meal i guess so
that works for those two
but reminder that only for while we're
doing this show do you guys get
what do you remember what you get while
we're doing the show 25
off and zero delivery great one of you
remembers
yeah that's off your first order of 15
or more when you download the doordash
app
and enter code nerd fitness again you
get
25 off zero delivery
phase right you have to sing it that way
a quarter of the price is gone
removed up to a 10 value uh and no
delivery fees when you download the door
dash app in the app store enter code
nerd fitness
what's that code nerd fitness
25 off your first order from doordash
who's also providing
sunday's healthy and cheap meals for our
little twinsies here
eric tommy what do you guys want to
cheat with i want
a big plate of buffalo wings baby i'm
dying for them i miss my wingies uh eric
i remember how tommy wanted to get a
burger a previous week and i think he
wasn't able to get it so i want tommy's
burger
i eat your burger and i want you to
throw in some
tempura green beans in there too okay
that's very specific
uh i will remind you that tommy
specifically requested a big
ass burger bring on a quarter pound
of ass in burger patty form i want that
asperger yes
so that's coming your way potentially uh
depending on how you guys perform
in the challenge and also in today's
workout
let's get limber yes
[Music]
you see that woman over there she's a
hydra agent working for yellow jacket
who's yellowjacket he's that one played
by corey stoll he's kind of forgettable
or whatever but
he has that insane goop gun
oh yeah he shoots the guy in the
bathroom
anyway point is she's trying to smuggle
pen particles in that purse
but also i bumped into her earlier and i
think i heard the vial break
oh dear is she okay yeah yeah she's fine
but you you bumped it or did you
apologize
she's a hydra agent ma'am does this man
hurt
the point is she's trying to take pin
particles in that bag so your mission is
to shrink down
get in there collect as many particles
as you can and put them back in the vial
and then i don't know we
we beat her up and steal her but i
didn't really script this part got it
i'll seduce her no no we do not need you
to seduce anybody
okay let's see what happens no please do
not seduce the only skills you're going
to need are speed and stamina
so you do want me to seduce you no don't
use seduction okay
speed and stamina that's the name of the
game for me how about you focus on
defense defense goes up so you do want
me to suppress her
ma'am no quiet the person who collects
the most particles and gets them back in
their half of the tube before she gets
out the door
wins all right here she comes you ready
you have your watches
shrink down let go
whoa all right guys she's on her way out
the door
oh no so i'm starting in three two
one go but everything's weirdly to scale
oh the gravity's different
daddy phillip i've never been in a
ladies purse before but i've always
wanted to be
i've gotten zero i'm not doing great
eric yeah well
you're balls
that's nice that's not supposed to go in
the vial
let's go in oh i'm on a roll baby
hey fade away god i'm using the
chapstick
oh hey more balls
how are you so good use that phone to
call health because you suck at this
okay that's it dear diary tommy bullied
me
right now we could create a burn book
i'm gonna loosen your pin vial tommy why
are you trying to score stuff in eric's
pinball
i'm trying to block it so he can't throw
anywhere in there we're trying to save
the world
[Music]
i'm gonna take a video of how
embarrassing you are right now you have
to turn the camera around you have to
turn the camera no it's front-facing
like viral comedians
yeah it's not as good a quality if it's
front-facing you're not as good at
quality when you're front-facing
oh i have to throw them in i've just
been collecting them like apples oh my
apples it's not an easter egg hunt eric
everything's an easter egg hunt damn it
life is an easter egg cud
what are you doing over there hey you
can't taste those those are my pen
particles they don't tell jack what he
can't do
[Music]
all right here we go fly my pretties
none of them went in you know what
i'm just mad at the files because i'm
mad at my poor lack of
physical skill i'm just gonna erase
myself
[Music]
all right ted no those are by far eight
seven
make it rain five four
two look how they massacred my boy
no one wins no one wins they're only
losers
does anyone have any orange slices yeah
i feel like i gained a little weight on
the up
swing you know when i was down there i
was at my goal weight of about two
ounces
shrunk down but now uh you know
you guys done i think we did a great job
i'm really proud of you i think you did
a great job
okay first of all hydra 100 has all
those pin particles now
well no that's one way of looking at it
they already they did particles
so you know if you the status quo didn't
change you actively helped by pouring
out
tommy's side and then yet somehow still
managed to lose the challenge
you know you set us against each other i
felt i saw
red yeah something changes in him where
he becomes very threatening when you pit
us against each other you are in
competition with each other okay see i
keep forgetting that yeah who's the real
i thought this was a dating show for the
first two months it it still can be and
i'm falling for both of you
and the purse lady i don't know what's
going on these are new feelings for me
who do you guys think deserves to win
that me definitely i mean i i mean
thomas
neither of you you both cheated and you
both lost the mission
it's gonna come down to how you did
throughout the week i'll do the math on
that
you guys should be ashamed of yourselves
if you're not cheating you're not trying
boys yeah baby yeah let's go
well well well you guys had the night to
sleep on it uh
and what you did how do you guys feel
about yourselves how do we feel you're
the one who bumped into that poor hydra
agent
he's a hydra agent ma'am wherever you
are he's not
here you guys caused hydra to get away
with thin particles
and you cheated and you sabotaged each
other yeah it got a little nasty down
there but when you're shrunken you have
a shorter
temper i'm glad he did what he did
you're glad that he sabotaged you
yeah you want to know why because i saw
the worst and the best of him down there
in that purse there was a moment when i
was filming him with that giant cell
phone where i looked through the lens
and i saw beauty
that i had never seen before well tommy
let's tell philip the real why we
sabotaged it
hell hydra oh damn it wait i feel like
everybody's hydra at this point it's
just the fun group to be a part of these
days
speaking of fun groups to be a part of
these days
i wanna like give you guys an update i
am no longer
uh in cahoots with pizzazz i am
cooperating with the fbi
in a pretty large federal sting and we
last night i'm happy to say
pizzazz is now in federal custody and
according to the terms of my cooperation
my 25-year loan has been reduced down to
an 18-year loan with a boy named mark
shark
uh i was trying to buy a lebron james
rookie card from him
he called me a cuck and a simp and then
told me that i was on the hook for 18
years and i said what are you my son
so that's where i'm at with peloton all
right well judgment time
will come soon enough for both of you
for pizzazz for pizzazz junior
uh specifically now for you guys we have
these poor delivery driver drivers at
your door please go meet them
oh okay so yes both of these guys
cheated miserably they absolutely
allowed hydra to get access to pimp
articles which i'm sure won't have any
future repercussions
but regarding the week they actually
both did pretty decent i really love
that tommy did
want to go so much harder i do think he
ended up getting a bit
sidetracked with his new toy ended up
not hitting his overall goals for the
week quite as hard as eric did so
since the challenge was a wash our
winner is
hey look at our winners yes
wait huh how did you also win wait a
second
oh
mine's real vegan bonus wings they have
like the same amount of calories if i
wanted all the regret and half the taste
i would have called my ex-wife
no one was checking on me while i was
having this psychotic break for a second
here
oh i feel sorry real quick yes tommy you
got some delicious uh
veggie buffalo wings i believe and eric
how's that
sweet sweet asperger tastes like ass no
it's
it's really good i miss cheeseburgers so
much
did we get those stupid
all right all right guys that's it for
this week's episode of fitness origins
i've been phillip molina and i'll see
you next week on fitness origins
and i've been ass
just been asked i've been ass no jokes
these are [ __ ] delicious
[Music]
you